翻訳: Keisuke Yamashita
校正: Kyoko Kamura
みなさんが住んでいる町
この町を「自分で作ろう」と
思ったことがある人はいますか？
この中に —
「町を作る」
はい よかったです
ここで手が上がったら
僕の話 ここで終わるんで
（笑）
僕は仕事を通じて
気づいたことがあります
それは「自分の町は自分で作る」
ということなんです
今日は僕から「自分の町は自分で作る」
そんな話をしたいと思います
もともと僕は建設資材のメーカーに
勤めていました
そうですね ちょうどその頃 今から５年前
ある事件が起きたんです
それは 僕の大好きな実家の周りが
スラム街になってしまったんです
それは実家の賃貸住宅で
起こったことなんです
まぁ時代の流れで
空室がどんどん増えていって
ついにそのうちの一棟が
全員退居して
空き家になってしまったんです 完全に
これです
まぁ 寂れた雰囲気
ちょっと怖い感じですよね
そう 僕がちっさい時には
すごく賑やかだったんです この辺りも
お店がたくさんあって
子どももたくさんいた
ただ40年間で
様変わりしてしまいました
で ここで収入が
無くなってしまったので
この建物を維持することが
できなくなってしまったんです
そこで 父親が
僕に相談をくれました
「ちょっとどうしようかな…？」と
で 僕 言ったんです
「そしたらこの建物の使い方とか
見た目をごそっと変えて
全面改修して
もう一度 賃貸事業をやり直そう」
って言ったんです
そうしたら 父親が
「やめとけ やめとけ」と
「そんなに金をかけてどないすんねん
ここにはもう人はこないぞ」と
相談しといて なんで反対すんねん
と思ったんですけど
（笑）
そうなんです 実はここは
立地が悪いところなんです
で 今まで いろんなことを
やったんですけど
なかなかうまく行かなかった
だから反対するのも
しょうがないなと思いました
だけど 反対を押し切って
その全面改修をスタートさせるんです
それは僕には信念があったんです
自分が住みたいなと思う家を作ったら
必ずそれに応えて 人は来てくれる
っていう信念がありました
だから この全面改修には
僕がいいなと思うことを
たくさん盛り込んだんです
床は無垢のフローリング
気持ちがいいんです
壁は自由に塗ってもいいんです
紙のクロスにしました
そしてリビングは
広い土間にしたんです
アトリエのようにしたんです
普通の賃貸住宅では
あまり見られない仕様なんです
僕はこの建物に「イノハウス」
っていう名前を付けました
自然素材の「イノセンス」と
革命の「イノベーション」という
「イノ」を掛けて
そしたら面白かったんです
驚いたことに 工事中にもかかわらず
たくさん問い合わせをいただいて
完成前に満室になったんです
そして もっと面白かったのが
ここに集まった人たち
デザイナー 革職人
イラストレーター
凄くクリエイティブで
アクティブな人たちが集まったんです
何だか一体感があって
これは面白そうなことが起こりそうだなと
そんな感じがしました
で これは完成パーティーの時なんです
住民の人 その友達 それから町の人
たくさんの人が集まったんです
半年前には「ここに人は来ない」
って言われた場所です
賑わいが生まれたんです
そしてこの賑わいが
この後も続いていくんです
なんか日常が変わって来たな —
そんな感じがしました
何気ない挨拶が増えたんです
この建物の周りとか
人がいないと言われたところに
なんか人が外に出てるんです
僕も用も無いのに行きたくなった
賃貸経営をなんとか立て直したい
その想いで仲間と一緒に
イノハウスを作ったんですけど
何か想定とは違う
何か別のものを町に作れた
そういう風に思ったんです
「あー これって何かな？」
って思ったんです
「あっ！ これ『まちづくり』だ」
「よし これを仕事にしよう」
ってその時 思いました
このまちづくりは自分のやるべきことだって
そういう風に強く思ったんです
強く思っちゃったから
会社を辞めました
（笑）
会社を辞めて それで
まちづくりをしようと
このイノハウスで起こったことが
ずーっと 町に広がったら
これ絶対おもしろいことになると
そういう風に思ったんです
ずーっと広く考えると
ちょっとイメージし辛かったんです
いろいろ合意形成とか大変だなぁ
そこで 祖父の代から管理している
このイノハウスを含む —
ちょうどこの直径100mの
このちっさなエリア
ここにちっさな町を作ろう
直径100mの町を作ろう
そう決心するんです
そして この場所の真ん中の空き地に
みんなで考えた
想いを込めた賃貸住宅を
まず建てることを決めて
それで このちっさな町に
名前を付けることにしたんです
「イノタウン」という名前を付けました
じゃあ今度は
イノハウスで起こったように
このイノタウンに クリエイティブで
アクティブな人に来てもらいたい
どうすればいいか
この企画には すでに入居している
デザイン事務所が参画してくれたんです
すでにいる人たちが主役になって
この場所を面白くするには
どうすればいいか一緒に考えてくれたんです
いや これ凄いことだと思います
そして みんなで考えるんです
この小さな町にどうやったら
そういうクリエイティブな人たちが
来てくれるか？
じゃあ 自分で作れる部屋を作ろう
そう 集まった人たちが
イベントをできる広場を作ろう
みんなが使える公民館のような
カフェを作ろう
ギャラリーを作ろう
シェアオフィスを作ろう
いろいろ企画をして
工事がスタートします
僕 銀行に行って
かなりお金を借りてきてですね
もうこれは後には引き返せません
もうドキドキなんです これ
で 建物が立って餅を撒きます
そしたら町の人が 200人くらい
集まってくれました
すごいですよね
で 工事中にマルシェをやりました
地域の人たちが手伝ってくれて
すごい盛り上がりました
で 建物が完成して
完成パーティーの時には
またたくさんの人が来てくれたんです
すごい嬉しかったです
そして募集をかけます
そしたら
この町に住みたいという人
この町にお店を出したいという人
できたカフェに
コーヒーを飲みに来てくれる人
いろんな人が集まったんです
人が人を呼ぶ感覚
すごく嬉しかったです
そしてもっとさらに面白かったのが
集まった人たちが
いろんな企画をするんです
音楽イベント —
これ去年なんですけれども
入居者さん同士で話して
クリスマスのマジックショーをやりました
それから マルシェもやります
こんなところに人は来ないよと
言われた場所に
賑わいが生まれたんです
町ができたんです
一般的にまちづくりっていうのは
住みやすい住環境づくり全般のことだとか
あと自治体レベルの都市計画なんかを
指したりします
少し大きなこと
だけど 僕たち仲間で
イノタウンを作っていく中で
大切だなって思ったのは
もっと身近なことに
目を向けることも
大切だなという風に思うんです
例えばふとした日常が楽しいだとか
一人ひとりが小さなことから始める —
まぁ そんなことです
イノタウンにいたら
挨拶があるんです
「おはよう」「こんにちは」
あと それ以外にも
名前で呼ばれるんです
僕 下の名前がたかひろなんで
「たかひろさん」って呼ばれるんです
で「お 昨日どうしてたん？」
「最近どう？」とか
人に関心持ったり 持たれたり
カフェに入ったら僕の知ってる人がいて
僕のことを知っている人がいる
そういう ふとした人と人とのつながり
ちょっと深い人と人とのつながり
これがふとした日常が楽しいなって
感じられることにつながると思うんです
この人と人とのつながり —
コミュニティ
だから僕はまちづくりっていうのは
コミュニティづくりに
置き換えられると思うんです
じゃあ コミュニティをどうやって作るか
そして どうやって継続するか
これが 課題なんです
で 僕たちが
小さな町づくりをやる中で
気づいた［ことが］３つあります
それは —
「同質の人を集める」
「場を設ける」
「きっかけ作りができる人を見つける」
この「同質な人を集める」というのは
同じような価値観を
持った人のことを言います
そういう人たちが集まれば
共感性が高まるんですよ
共感性が高まるコミュニティって
盛り上がるんですね
で イノタウンでは
こういう工夫があります
あえて収納を作らず
自分で作ってくださいとか
壁は自由に自分で塗ってもいいんです
こういうクリエイティブな感覚を
刺激するような仕掛けを
たくさん入れることによって
それが楽しい それがいいという人だけが
集まって入居するんです
なので 共感性の高いコミュニティが
生まれるんです
「場を設ける」
人が集まるためには 場所が必要なんです
じゃあ どんな場所でもいいのか
いや そうじゃないんです
やっぱり運営が必要なんですよ
毎日行きたいなって
思えるような場所が必要です
毎日行きたいなって思えるような場所 —
じゃあどうするか？
イノタウンでは 賃貸住宅の中に
カフェを作りました
このカフェは収益を目的としたカフェじゃなく
コミュニティ形成を目的としてます
公民館のようなカフェ
そして次に
「きっかけづくりができる人を見つける」
これ 実は重要なんです
例えば 集まりがあって
ただ人が集まっていても何も起こりません
じゃあ 呑み会やろうとか
何かイベントを企画するような人
大事ですよね こういう人
こういう人が必要なんです
で イノタウンでは どういう風に
工夫をしたかというと
住宅と店舗を複合的に作るんです
実はこの店舗 お店
お店というのは商売上
町が賑わうことと利害が一致するんです
町が賑わったらお店儲かりますから
なので お店をちっさい町であっても
積極的に入れて
それで そのお店の人が コミュニティの
きっかけ作りをやってくれるんです
で 結果 継続したコミュニティが生まれる
同質の人が ある場所に集まって
そこにきっかけを作る人がいれば
共感性の高いコミュニティが生まれるんです
共感性の高いコミュニティは
２回 ３回 続くんです
人も増えるんです
そしたら 増えたら その中に
きっかけを作る人が またいるんです
それで継続していくんです
この継続っていうのがいいんですよ
こうやって僕の周りでは
町の拠点が増えていっているんです
何にもない住宅街の中にある
アパートの一室 空き家だったんです
ここに 地域の １人の女性が
在宅ワーカーが集まる拠点として
「コトノハコ」っていう場所を作りました
レンタルボックスを置いたら
地域の作家がたくさん集まって
自分の作品をここに置いて
販売するんです
そして ワークショップをすれば
そこに町の人が集まって
賑わいが生まれるんです
ただの空き家です
町の拠点になりました
シャッター街化が進む商店街の中で
起こったことなんです
20年前に閉店したトンカツ屋さん
ここが空き家になってたんです
で ここに １階に
コミュニティカフェを作って
２階に 外国人が宿泊できる
ゲストハウスを作ったんです
面白いでしょ？
そしたらこの１階[で]
外国人と町の人が交流を深めるんです
ミシンを置いたら
ものづくりが始まりました
面白い場所になっていって
で この場所を 地域の活動家に貸したら
いろんなイベントが
起こるようになりました
それで また人が人を呼ぶ
賑わいを生んだんです
さっきのやつとこれ 両方とも
もともとは ただの空き家だったんです
僕たちは 空き家を町の拠点に
再生することで
「まちづくり」をやっていってます
実はこのまちづくりっていうのは
誰でもできるんです
この出発点となる場所は
どこでもいいと思うんです
例えばみなさんの
身近にあるような —
行きつけのカフェとか 公園とか
自分の家とかでもいいと思うんです
そこに気の合う仲間と集まって
まちづくりを始めませんか？
なんでみなさんにこういうことを
言うかというと
みなさんの町の主役は
みなさん一人ひとりなんです
決して他人が作るものではないんです
ふとした日常が楽しいなと思える町は
自分一人ひとりで作るんです
最後に 僕から言います
いつ どこで 誰と
あなたは始めますか？
ありがとう
（拍手）